Fern defends magic in front of Zoltrak, who is
surprised. It's a
very advanced defense technique to prevent Zoltrak.
What does this mean? What does this mean? This is a
general attack magic.
It's magic,
Kubal. Your magic was too strong.
After you were sealed away, wizards all over the continent
researched and analyzed Zoltrak.
In just a few years, Zoltrak was
incorporated into the human magic system and became powerful with a new defensive technique.  With the
development of defensive magic, the
magic system using equipment has improved significantly, and
Zoltrak is no longer a magic that kills people, but is
now called general offensive magic.